bonjour tout le monde merci d'être venus
si nombreux pour rendre cet hommage à
notre collègue et ami alexandre vous
connaissiez bien mieux que moi
donc moi aussi c'est un relais qu on
penserait on ne peut pas oublier avec
qui j'ai démarré il se en mars
camille des symposiums des travaux
impérissable et il est avec nous
aujourd'hui
il est certes particulière mais je sais
qu'il va nous accompagner aujourd'hui
parce qu'il a dit à ses proches
il faudra continuer à travailler comme
j'ai toujours souhaité travailler au
sein de cette maison
vous connaissiez sa force il s'avère que
travaille évidemment poursuivre rendre
l'hommage aujourd'hui je vous invite
donc à observer
à
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde parle donc à millau iii du
losc que récent don camillo
nous alignons à l'époque avec la
consommation
ce soir une soirée de gala de remise des
prix des meilleurs sportifs de l'année
dans cette affaire sale état n'y arrive
pas le magic à la boutonnière dit voilà
donc à nous avec nous donc c'est tout le
monde reçoit alors un smart et du
premier tour violent tous les jeux ne
sera jamais plus rien ne sera jamais
plus ma présence
[Applaudissements]